- Patrick Turcotte voulait
semer dadans la vie de ses 300 .
Cette terre située derrière
son entreprise de camionnage
de la région de Drummondville
de parvenir à ses fins.
PATRICK TURCOTTE,
président, Groupe TYT
- J'ai vu le bout de terrain
était prêté au voisin pourde la:
ça, ce serait vraiment une bonne
place pour fairepour les employ.
On se cherchait toutes sortes
d'idées pour se réinventer,
des moyens de rétention, gâter
qu'avec tout le... le prix de
l'alimentation, sérieusementrie,
ce serait une bonne idée.
- Il a donc embauché
qui ont rapidement mis
la parcelle de terre à profit.
RACHEL GUILLEMETTE, maraîchère
- On fait beaucoupdes pommesdes,
on fait des carottes,
on fait des petites fèves.
Il y a tous les crucifères,
le brocoli, du chou-fleur.
On essaie de faire du chou
de Bruxelles, c'est un combat.
- Mis au fait du projet,
en solutions numériques
s'est joint à l'aventureventuree
pour redonner au suivant.
LOUIS-PHILIPPE BARIL,
- Nous autres, la valeur
numéro 1, c'est le, c'est le, c,
puis le plaisir, bien ça,
c'en est un, grand plaisir,ir.i.
Puis, de pouvoir redonner aussi
nt, autant à l'interne
qu'à l'externe, fait que ça,
ça rejoignait vraiment
que l'initiative, elle a étéado.
- Environ 120 paniers de
légumes frais àe semaine
aux employés intéressés.C'est ss
distribués au Comptoir
alimentaire Drummond.
nos terminaux, que ce soit
à Québetréal ou à
Drummond, on s'organise pour
acheminer ces bacs de légumes-là
- L'initiative semble
de toute évidence appréciée
par les principaux intéressés.
HUGO MÉNARD,
nous permet de bénéficier
de bons légumes bio toutela seÇe
notre employeur pense à nous
et qu'il veut nous garder.
employée, Nmédia
- Sur le prix, c'est super
intéressant, sur la qualité
des légumes, sur l